the British Medical Association says
that Julia doctors need a 35 pay rise to
make up the blow inflation Rises for
many years and the BMA Junior doctors
committee co-chair Dr Rob Lorenson joins
us now thanks very much for being good
morning look everyone knows the
important role that Junior doctors play
in the house service is there strike
action four days is that going to put
lives at risk I don't think so and
actually the NHS has shown itself to be
very resilient over our last action
which was last week over a 72 hour
period where many Healthcare
professionals like consultants and
Associate Specialists were able to
provide and support care in services
like a e and intensive care there's a
lot of appointments canceled though
isn't that I mean there's already a huge
backlog anyone who's waiting for an
appointment knows that there is and
that's precisely one of the big
arguments that we're trying to put
forwards there's a massive Workforce
crisis in doctors and other Healthcare
Professionals in the NHS and I just want
to draw a comparison to a normal working
day if a Consultants were to go off sick
or if they were unable to attend their
Clinic duties we'd see all of those
appointments rescheduled and they would
be rescheduled for months in advance
which demonstrates how little Workforce
capacity we have so these struck this
strike action yes it causes disruption
and I'm sorry for that but it just
demonstrates that we have 9 9000
vacancies and secondary care we have six
thousand fewer GPS and it's very
difficult for patients to Access
healthcare that they deserve let's talk
numbers you want a 35 pay rise it's a
pretty big pay rise
so doctors have lost 26.1 over the last
15 years in real terms and what we're
asking for is for that to be restored so
we're asking for it to go back to a
cost-neutral point of view from 2008 and
what that looks like is about a five to
ten pound an hour increase at the moment
doctors start on 14 pounds an hour and
we're just asking that to that for that
to be restored to 19 pounds now I think
look lots of people would be like look
Junior doctors are underpaid and you've
had as you say a whole 15 years has
squeezed but is it realistic to be asked
to clip the fingers at these times of
economic difficulties and make up for 15
years worth of below inflation pay Rises
it's not going to happen is it so so
there are some challenges that we need
to work out in the negotiation room and
so yeah
is that what you're saying so I think
there's many different ways to be able
to get to full pay restoration and I
think it's really important but when we
talk about realism or the reasonability
of it I think think what what's happened
is is that Mr Barkley and ourselves are
just at different points and trying to
tackle this issue he's coming at it from
quibbling over about one billion pounds
which when you put into perspective of
the test and Trace budget yeah it's very
easy to look at the PPE isn't it
because I understand it's easy to look
at the amount of money that was spent
during covet but at the time we were in
the middle of a global pandemic people
didn't know what was going on it was
right so at the time some would argue to
put money into things that could try and
make a difference right now everyone is
about titling across the board we've
seen nurses making a deal we've seen
teachers uh getting around the table as
well and for many people you guys look
like an outline
so you know absolutely and this is what
I'm saying so Mr Barclay is coming at it
from complaining about one billion
pounds we're coming at it and saying
look we have a health care crisis at the
moment we have 500 excess deaths 500
British people dying needlessly a week
in Winter and we're trying to address
real Health Care crises and so we're
trying to approach this from a
perspective of doctors looking after
patients and wanting to deliver high
quality health care and Mr Barclay is
just trying to pinch pennies
except pinch padding and penny pinching
a 35 pay rise I think if you were to ask
the ordinary person on the street would
they be happy to pay a doctor 7 P.M on a
Friday night 19 pounds an hour I think
you'd get a resounding yes that's
reasonable uh we're streeting the man
who could be Health secretary in 18
months time at Labor's Shadow said this
on Friday on LBC I don't support the
strike actually I don't want the strike
to go ahead what's your message to labor
uh well I would be happy to work with
anyone who was in power to be able to
deliver full pay restoration for doctors
again you know this is about trying to
address serious Workforce crisis that
that are putting each and every one of
us at risk every winter
Mr streetings made some comments about
not supporting strike but he did make a
comment about understanding the argument
for full pay restoration and I think
that's the difference that we have
um between Mr streeting and Mr Barkley
Mr Barkley doesn't even recognize the
stresses and the pressures that Junior
doctors are under and that's why we're
so far apart why are you not getting
around the table oh no we're very happy
to get around the table so next week
will Mark six months since we started
our formal trade dispute and Mr
Barkley's only come to the table twice
it's really very difficult to be able to
talk to someone who doesn't even want to
invite us in and indeed on Wednesday he
left the room
what happens
he asked us uh um you know what we would
like to talk about we presented our
opening position on what we think would
constitute full pay restoration and how
we'd like to work with him but he didn't
ask us any further questions he didn't
ask us to hi do you think you got into
your heart so I think one billion pounds
for 75 000 Junior doctors to be able to
try and treat the massive Workforce
crisis and to be able to deliver high
quality care to the people of this
country I think that's value for money
okay thank you very much for coming on
the program it's good to have you here
explain your position thank you much
appreciated